oh
This is Muriwai Beach in New Zealand
This is a sheep and this is gandalf
Most people come to new zealand to check out the country's unmatched beauty and to get their middle-earth fix and that makes perfect sense
But on this trip. I'm hunting for something else
something less obvious
I'm after the innovations being brought to life behind these doors
in these buildings and
in this studio
I'm heading out on a 400 mile journey across new Zealand's, North Island from Auckland to Wellington to find the most breathtaking
Inventions these kiwis have cooked up. You said it wasn't gonna be Friday. This is the first one that's going to go on yep
The computer model has just become conscious of something on this episode of how the world will check out a mad scientist
some [Rockets]
And an AI baby hi, baby, I'll either warm your heart
Or leave you weeping over humanity's grim future
Silicon Valley may be home to some of the biggest tech giants in the world, but it's being challenged like [never] before
Crazy Tech geniuses have popped up all over the planet making things that will blow your mind
My name is Ashley vance. I'm an author and journalist and I'm on a quest to [find] the most innovative Tech creations and
Meet the beautiful freaks behind them hello world
oh
Hello, Sky [Fellas]
This is auckland
The home to 1.5 million of New Zealand's 4.5 million people
People living outside of Oakland 10 Tanaka Des congested and hectic
Meanwhile people living in auckland celebrate the way of life it offers. [I] [guess] that a lot of place everybody's going [to] go to
The City has a bustling food scene
There's a gorgeous harbour surrounded by fertile volcanic land and those gannets and black sand beaches you saw earlier
There just a half hour drive from downtown
This next [parts] gonna sound cheesy but honest to God, it's true
Auckland is full of cheery uptil mystic people to feel good when you're here like you can do stuff big stuff
crazy stuff like say replicating human consciousness on the inside of a computer
Face it's our primary means of communication
Yeah
But it's been untapped in terms of a human-computer interface
here
Dr.. Peter can Express itself to you in a human-like way, which is emotional that's cognitive, no
That's when you start getting to [this] sort of interesting place. Go on a cai, baby
on a sunny afternoon
The fellow you meet next is a Madman in the best possible way [Gonna] pull the muscles which basically lower the brow
He's Mike sager a computer scientist at the University of Auckland
So nice [rain] [clem] would be yesterday's [wanker], and she's noise up
mark became famous for building super detailed simulations of the human body and
ended up winning a couple of oscars for his work on films like avatar and King Kong sorry stay here and
These days mark is how to put this?
trying to reverse engineer the human brain
He's built a series of simulations around how the human face moves how we express emotion and how our neurons fire?
we're trying to build a computer which has
experiences can IMagine and
Basically it has its own sort of existence in a way. So now what we're gonna do is I'm going to run baby s
What we're building here is a computer that can learn
So this is baby
Please sort of looking at us and hearing us if I make a loud noise
And I should get a fright. This is what she can see so you can see my face here a through that [eye]
so she's not
Copying my smile
She's responding to me and now this is her little fist baby's fist weird book
So you can pick a bigger page in a show or something, but she has to be looking at it's a get her attention
Hi, baby, hi, hi
Hi, what do you see?
What's this?
Puppy very good. What's that baby?
This is cuz we're new zealand you [gotta] show your shape. Yeah, I'll give her the word yeah. Yeah, hi baby, hi
What do you see, baby?
Sheep very good, baby
the long-term goals is can we create a
Computational model of consciousness because then you get go okay the computer model has just become conscious of something is that thought on
Now all the facial expressions everything is driven by neural nets so as we look [around]
I'm going [at] his nails remove her face basically and so this is what's driving in the background
And so what you're looking at now these are all the connections lighting out right as the baby's doing stuff
And this is like a simulation of what [would] you have an ingress in this brain?
Yeah, because if you're going to make a character biological and behave naturally then you've got to use a natural model
so this is sort of what's going on inside baby X
Now we take this stuff, and we [a] now connect it to cognitive computing systems. So you've got
Biological Neural Networks connected to artificial intelligence models and the potential for that's enormous
That's where the future is probably going to be
There's a term new zealanders have for possessed inventor types like [Mark]
They're part of the country's number 8 wire culture like so many things here the story of number 8 wire goes back to those sheep
Farmers used to make their fences out of [eight] wire gauge metal
Then they started to use the wire to fix just about any problem on the farm over time a number 8 wire
mythology evolved to capture the Can-do spirit of people living in a remote place and
other people who had to solve problems in any clever way they could
But while new zealanders remain fond of the 8 wire idea there's an undeniable sense that the country [is] ready to level up
It's time to start inventing with more purpose and polish
the Gritty Garage Workshop is giving way to this a
Pristine mad scientist's Lab that looks like it could be for sale [in] an apple [store]
[Sarey] avery embodies kiwi ingenuity
He's a prolific scientist and inventor sir avery this is Ashley vance
He made a fortune in the pharmaceutical industry and then decided to dedicate his life to helping the world's poorest people
Hence the sir all right this way so cool house all right. It's a to the Magic wardrobe I
Followed sir avery through a [wardrobe] door into his garage slash lab where he creates his objects I?
Knows everything of the houses. [why] did you're wearing white yeah? Yeah? Yeah, I mean, [I'm] a bit like Steve jobs
I have two dresses. I have black for winter and white for summer the thing is that I know that I've got
4,795 days left to live how do you know that well because I've done the algorithm
Analysis of somebody my age born in my time how much Chardonnay are drains all that sort of so
I know what I'm going to do with the next ten years of my [life] failure is
Really just for people are unprepared you don't waste time on
Things that aren't going to get you to where you need to go in things like clothes
Sir avery is well known for taking complicated medical devices and making them simple cheap and durable
Did you make this in here? Yeah? Yeah, this is your workshop lab, okay? Currently he's working on this incubator
It really is a life apart because it's almost like you know something that
Superman would be
Happy to be in and the shape of it is really much more about getting even air distribution and trying to make it look all
The life Pod costs
$2,000 versus
$40,000 for typical incubators the hope is that it could save thousands of lives each year
I'll tell you this is really cold. This is oh my God, [okay]
[so] free pretty pretty ugly he also has this giant block of frozen chicken slurry as a way to amplify the
nutritional value of trash meat, that's after Kentucky fried
Have taken all their bits the legs and the chest mate make it into this stuff mmM chicken slurry just have a spoonful that later
Sir a remixes the trash meet with of all things kiwi this breaks it down into the basic amino acids
So your body can absorb the nutrients more easily
It's aimed at helping malnourished children if you take that then you're going to get instant energy
You don't need to digest it. Go straight across [your] gut this will save millions and millions of kids lives
you know Einstein said the most elegant solution is always the most simplest and
Kiwis have that a very practical way of doing things
if you take away
the noise that you have often with things like silicon Valley and just have a bunch of guys in sheds for the lathe and a
Few bits and pieces they come up with stuff that nobody able to thought off
Coming up. We'll take a look at rockets. This is a dream come true. I've always wanted to be in the back
Then I cheap that I'm hoping that I live after this relaxing afternoon
one of New Zealand's Most Adventurous
and affable inventors is a Scottish import named Richard little we know there's probably about five million people around the world that could benefit from
Using the rakes he's one of two engineers who started Rex Bionics
My best friend was diagnosed with multiple sclerosis and like the need to use a wheelchair in his future I
Said why don't we build your robot legs?
So we spend four years in the garage, and we actually got something working [it] [could] [sit] [in] [the] could stand and it could walk
We knew then we would be able to do this
So the thing you'll notice with the rex of course right away is itself support
and
It's the only device of its kind like that because of that most of the people who use rex or spinal cord injured
Although it can be any mobility impairment if you stand in it
If you push the Joystick forward and let it go
Will take one step and stop if you keep holding it forward? I'll keep moving forward okay. What is the red button?
Do that's the emergency scale so if it all turns the custard press the red button, okay?
So if you push it forward and let it go, that's it. You're going to lean to that site, okay well
It's crazy. I mean you really don't have to put it [Eddy]. You don't do anything. Yeah
Going to be Michael Jackson impression
This is jared
He lost the use of his legs in a car accident [ten] years ago, and is now a [wrecks] employee
Customer and test driver. How long would you use it each day use it for an hour day? [oh], give me a couple of days
paint relief off my lovely
It's safe, and it's general in general [in] the [skinners] general in the bones
When you sit in a wheelchair all the time, you know you lose bone density
It causes skin issues bowel, or Bladder and the Act of walking helps resolve it
I've taken it home and walked into my local bar because all I do you know walk back in there for the first time
Ever drink with my mates standing up around a [bar] [leader] and to the people to borrow what a trace
Yeah, the day. I was 17 you
Later we raced up mount Eden to catch the sunset
It's here on top of a volcano that you reminded how young this landscape and people are
industry only began here in earnest in the 1850s and yet [new] [zealand] has come an awfully long way and
the next stop for New zealand [that]
[would] be space
I think new Zealanders don't think big enough
they don't go after the really big problems and the big billion-dollar ideas I
Started building rockets when I was at school
And the very first rocket that I built [I] ended up putting on a bicycle
Most Rocket companies are started by wealthy governments and billionaires
Rocket Lab was started in 2007 by this maniac
Peter Beck
Peter is [one] of the most capable people on the planet
He never went to college
Opting instead to hone his own engineering craft in the garage and machine shops. [oh], I don't know why rockets make me so happy
Now he wants to make [it] much easier and cheaper to put small satellites into space
If you had to set a lot on your lap right [now] in one week, I can have not an orbit moreover
I can have that on orbit an order magnitude less cost than any other way of getting it there
The first rocket launch will take place later this year wow this is the first one. That's Gonna go up yep
Commercial customers have already signed up, and there's a two-year waiting list [how] much are you gonna charge per flight weight 4.9 million dollars okay?
For point nine million dollars might seem like a lot
But it's actually a remarkable figure and liftoff of the Falcon 9 rocket and dragon
The cheapest way to get to space today is on one of elan musk [rockets] from Spacex and that costs sixty million dollars per trip
Propulsion Performing [Amelie]
Rocket labs prices would open space to a whole new set of customers including scientists and businesses and in effect
democratize space
This is what the aerospace world has dreamed of for decades. This is the second stage second stage [gym]. You can lift it up. Yeah
You rolled your eyes a little bit of this eight wire thing why is that if someone says you know rocket lab is a number
Right [water] company, they'll get you sorted off
The side just gone because number a wire it's about sort of bodging stuff together to make network
and it's really not what new zealanders have evolved to it's about really high Tech innovation and doing really really clever things with
Large day approaching the pressure is on
Today, they're running an engine test at a site near the auckland airport
[so] the worst case scenario a blog hop blows up in the best case is how does it deal or shut down?
Building a company is hot yeah building [a] rocket company damn near [insane]
I hitched a ride with peter to the test site and arrived just in time for Countdown three
The engine test was successful, but there's still a ways to go
What does it feel like in your gut that countdown clock in the office and everything that comes with sleep much?
It's probably the best answer to that question with a bit of luck Peter will maintain his sanity through 2017
That's when rocket lab plans to start flying for paying customers
This is a tiny company of a hundred people that will have bested entire nations and firmly put New zealand Stamp on the world
That's not eight wire culture. That's just flat-out amazing
And with that it's now time to leave auckland and Journey to Middle-Earth
We could have flown from Auckland, Wellington, and it would have taken an hour
But we wanted to be basted in Hobbit Vibes
We had to see the land
dear laptop
New Zealand is everything they said it would be
[plus] Burger [o's] smells like meat take Slice or grind
If aliens ever visit Earth and want to see what it has to offer
[their] first stop would have to be New zealand
It's like a sampler platter of landscapes
Rolling Hills
deserts Plains
Tropical forests whizzing by one after another
That's it for now. Thanks for listening laptop love Ashley
Three hours outside of auckland, we made a pit stop in a hot spring
All the times leading into this place for you that you'll get meningitis if you stick your head under water
I'm hoping that I live after this relaxing afternoon
Now before I learn about the meningitis the more afraid I have that I have the vagina
You know you come to new zealand, and it's all a wire cultures. You can set up [rockets]
Xt you know dunk your head underwater that you're dead, so [let's] [employ]
[slut] is cool. Just reminds me of love it living her out of my brain
Coming up next on hello world action. I steal Peter Jackson's camera, okay, wait
You've got a run for [safety] and get sucked into virtual reality
Welcome to a rainy and famously Windy, Wellington New Zealand's capital City and home to a thriving film industry
Director Peter Jackson is the local boy made good
He famously made lord of the rings here, and then shot past being a one-hit wonder
peters created an entire movie industry based around his film production company wetty
This is well. II would it's just like hollywood, but without any of the glitz and [glamour]
Studio [lots] and sound Stages are dull and unmarked they're tucked into a quiet suburb called Miramar
Wetty has started to expand into virtual reality and I was invited to take a look at their first
Vr. Movie [a] scene from the Hobbit where Smaug wakes up from a nap
You said it wasn't gonna be fried a thief in the shadows
It's crazy bad. I mean you feel like real emotions. What you see it
That's the nice thing moving [fuhrer] you get the people get such much more emotional experience than seeing something like a videogame or whatever [I]?
Think that's kind of where the space
We're in the content generation in the custom technology on the software side to kind of enable these these high-end experiences
Next the studio where they filmed Lord of the rings
[I] just want to grab that and have a look around
Where I got a crash course in motion Capture filmmaking using Peter Jackson's very own custom-made camera
Which isn't really a camera, but more of a device to place a director in a virtual world
There's a screen on the top that shows a rough version of the final graphics while dozens of sensors around the room
Record all [of] the cameras movements all you've got to do is yell action yep
They'll do this stuff, and you say cut like any other film actually
Get inside
Hey good way. You've got a run same thing this tech brings a human element back to green screen filmmaking
It's more tactile
It makes the director actually feel like he's shooting the film again [alright] cut
really good sport
When it became an industry of its own and after the success of lord of the rings [spawned] startups that are their own mini wettest
I'm actually
On my last stop [I] went to one of these startups [8I] studios
It's a Vr. Company that is recording people in three dimensions to bring them into virtual reality the
[difference] from looking at a video to seeing a hologram that looks just like the real thing
[is] so powerful a tie is developing software that will bring Vr to the masses?
The day you can capture a loved one in virtual space is almost here
We'll show you some experiences where we've captured some humans with off-the-shelf cameras
It feels like you're in the room with a person to check it out sure
[alright], so you can see the room yep?
alright, so oh
Hello, we create a virtual environment
But then we capture a very lifelike motion of the cloth and the human performance and we can compose those together
So you'd been a wet ever used to making these CGI fantastic creatures
But it just wouldn't work for a normal person that happened
You don't want to drop a visual effects, Hollywood production budget just to record your child
Experiencing the first step right and as we saw that these headsets were coming along there was no clear efficient cheap
scalable solution to capture reality and to author
Experiences at a scale and a realism and have a pace that would create a similar sort of content database for people to enjoy
Let's see how your fear [of] heights is so this is Gonna be like a movie. Oh
my God
That's crazy because I'm sort of like afraid of heights
oh
I
Mean I felt like I was gonna like walk off a cliff. That was really Friday
Although I was a bit skeptical it was time to scan myself
So I could meet the virtual Ashley
Which way do I look like this way you have to look anywhere, okay?
You're captured from from all sides [so] have fun, [and] I just have to stay in the circle pretty much
I was surrounded by 30 cameras all perfectly spaced and measured it was like in ocd
Paparazzi, I'm Ashley vance except I'm not really ashley vance. I'm a digital [asset]. That's being made at a ThAi studios
And then in post they put together all those different angles to make a final 3D version of me
If you [want] [to] get really nerdy this is called volumetric
cinematography just for the nerds
hands and pockets
Hands and pockets it since my little virtual friend
So I get to see my virtual self. Yes
You've seen yourself many many times in 2d video, so I think I would be underwhelmed
I think I'm just [gonna] see what I always look like in the mirror
I don't know why seeing like a 3D version of yourself would be a big deal
I would much rather be chased by [smog] so I can just walk around that yeah
That's kind of strange
The details it's saying maybe you can see like whiskers, right yeah
I mean the cameras are just that good and we're looking to increase that resolution as well, Kira sausage
Step into yourself. [oh], [that] is crazy
Well, I also did [not] know where I was in the roof
So I thought it would be really janky, and I mean it is [lifelike]
You know and so [that] I guess was [the] biggest surprise for me
So you think people are going to want Vr to be human?
I've got two boys and they grew up so quick
And it's like oh
Man, if you could just remember how they talked and their gestures and the funny things they said that would be really cool
here's the thing about new zealand its economy today depends on sheep cows and tourists and
Everyone knows that needs to change
Technology is the Country's future
Thanks to companies like rocket lab rex bionics and [8i] the change is already underway
foreign investors have started to pour money into New Zealand and
Engineers are staying at home because there are good jobs to be [had] if you're an outsider looking to come here
Well, why not the scenery [is] breathtaking?
The weather is good and the 8 wired days have passed
New zealand is taking on some of the hardest problems in the industry. It's working on the technology of the absurd
In the next episode of hello world [I] go to sweden and hang out with moose Hunters at the Arctic Circle
Take over the country's electrical grid seems incredible to raise the two people would handle half a country's power and eat cinnamon buttons with spotify
Is Daniel [Act] like it seems more wholesome than like a cinnabon. Yeah